hey this is Craig Cannon and you're
listening to Y Combinator's podcast
today's episode is a conversation about
business schools and startups with Jeff
bus gang a lecturer at HBS and GP at
flybridge Capital Partners Jeff called
in to talk with YC CEO Michael Seibel
after Michael was tweeting about trends
he saw in YC applications from MBAs and
since we recorded this interview HBS has
actually announced a joint degree that
combines their MBA with an MS degree
I'll link that up in the show notes
where you can also read the transcript
okay here we go
okay so on April 10th of this year
Michael tweeted reading YC applications
and observing that business schools are
doing a criminally poor job of prepping
students to start tech companies yes and
Jeff then replied what did you say Jeff
well I said as a professor at HBS I was
particularly intrigued by the tweet a
lot of my students are applying to YC
and I know we take a lot of pride
Harvard is trying to prepare our
students to be great founders and to be
effective in the startup plan cool so I
wanted to break apart a little bit like
why you actually thought that and if the
if the opinions of Silicon Valley and
the MBA world actually match each other
in terms of when you look at the data so
I think the thing that kind of triggered
the frustration is that most people
don't realize that as YC partners we
have to read approximately 500 of the 6
to 7,000 applications that come in every
batch and so this usually involves two
weeks of extremely intensive application
reading and the piece that kind of
triggered it was after you know the sub
countless number of applications from
MBA students that were clearly missing
kind of basic core tenets of what YC
would consider a qualification for doing
a start-up and I think what clicked in
my head wasn't so much the idea that
whether business schools are good or bad
at teaching entrepreneurship in terms of
in a classroom setting but just more
that business schools tend to be
expensive and these are extremely simple
rules that either these students didn't
know or didn't realize we're important
and that was extremely frustrating
because it's one thing to teach someone
accounting or you know case studies
about previous companies so and so forth
but there are probably three to five
kind of core YC tenants that if you
don't know or you don't do you don't get
into YC and so I think that's what
really triggered the outreach and it was
great because to be honest a number of
business schools reached out and kind of
it started a dialogue and I started
realizing a little bit more kind of what
I'm facing here in my way what are the
things you're facing I think that it's
extremely what I think unfortunately YC
has created this model for
entrepreneurship that people are trying
to replicate and it's extremely hard to
replicate everybody wants to have an
incubator but man like it's a hard model
ending to very specifically it's
extremely hard for the people who are
leading entrepreneurship efforts in a
school it's hard for schools to recruit
entrepreneurs to do this work and so
it's really hard to learn how to do a
start-up from someone who's never going
to startup before and that tends to be
the case for the a lot of people running
these programs tonight can I throw in
something here please yeah so first I
love Michael's tweet and I love our
back-and-forth because I think it does
put the spotlight on this question of
how do you prepare students to get out
into the field and be great
entrepreneurs and that's something that
we think about a lot and what wifey's
framework represents is pretty general
for all of start-up land I don't think
there's anything I mean there's a lot
that's unique about whyphy but I think
the tenants that we'll get into in a
minute
four tenets that we're trying to teach
in general to all budding aspiring
entrepreneurs so I think putting the
spotlight on encouraging
of all times to take a step back and get
out of the ivory tower and get into the
field be more practical and be more
attuned to what's happening in start-up
land I think is spectacular I agree with
you and what do you think historically
people have been doing wrong that has
led to this like preconceived notion
that MBA students are not are not ones
to create startups well first I don't
know if that's true if you look at the
data there's been a lot of great
companies founded by MBAs there's a
group called poets and quants that does
this analysis every year of the
unicorn's large high mountain value
startups that MBAs created I did a
couple of analyses on this a few years
ago there's a ton of examples whether
it's a cloud flare or Rent the Runway or
an earnest all three of them were
founded recently by Harvard Business
School alums there's a lot of great MBA
startups but I think this general set of
points that Michael is highlighting are
lessons for all entrepreneurs you know
for example one of the things we've gone
back and forth on there's this question
of research versus MVPs I think it's
just at NBA's because of their nature
may be more likely to fall into the
spinning too much research time mistake
as compared to a tech founder who's
going to be more likely to jump right in
and build something so I think it's it's
not that these lessons are not
applicable to all entrepreneurs they're
applicable to entrepreneurs that MBAs
are more susceptible to these mistakes
ugly and I think like - I totally agree
with that and I think that in many ways
the challenge here is that oftentimes an
MBA is either passively or actively
putting themselves forward as someone
who's received an education around
business issues and I think that like
when I think about that group of people
they should be doing disproportionately
well when pursuing startups and so to me
this is not a situation where I say Oh
an MBA applicant is worse than the
average YC applicant of course not and
and we accept tons of MBA applicants we
accepted a number of HBS applicants I
think the question that comes to my mind
is why aren't they doing
disproportionately better they should be
doing disproportionately better on
average they should be some of the best
applicants we see because the vast
majority of applicants have no formal
training mentoring or experience in the
classroom dealing with any issues around
startups and so I think that gap is what
I'm trying to figure out how we erase
and so what do you guys suspect are like
the the main issues right now that if
addressed MBA students would be more
successful disproportionately I it's
interesting because I'd love Jeff to
talk through like the causes this is
what I see is kind of the the red flags
so the first one is a lack of a
technical co-founder and the general
willingness to outsource the tech part
of a tech business the second one is
commitment it's you know can you get
your entire team committed to working on
this startup first and foremost as
opposed to we will do this startup if we
receive funding if we get into YC if a
variety of other criteria are met and
then I think the last one is what we
what I like to call traction which is
just basically this idea of how long
you've been working on this and what
have you done and that speaks to Jeff's
point around MVP versus research I think
research is and time is extremely
important but I think that being able to
do research with a live product is far
more valuable than being able to do
research with a general survey and so I
think those three things like time and
time and time again and don't be wrong
those are the central problems that most
YC applicants have but once again like I
would imagine that like within this
population these should not be the
things take
these hooks down yeah so I think the
root causes of the problems that
Michaels identify which are excellent
issues one of the root causes but a lot
of MBA programs are created in silos and
there may be technical talent in other
parts of the university but that
technical talent is inaccessible to the
MBA student they don't mingle every day
with engineers in the way they're
mingling every day with salespeople at
marketing people so that's a I think a
real issue that a lot of MBA programs
need to work on secondly there's not
enough technical proficiency within the
class you know this year for the first
time HBS started a club called HBS
coders there's been sales clubs as the
bargaining clubs are set in the fashion
clubs there's that there's gears but
there's never been a coders Club yet so
this year so that's a great sign but to
other mba programs have coder blogs and
you know what percent of the students
coming into these classes have technical
proficiency at middle with the bankers
at the edge funky fall of its solvent
yeah you know mix it up a little bit
help them with some of their technical
skills and prototyping skills and then
the final thing I'll say is there just
aren't enough practitioners walk in the
halls
Michael and I were having this
conversation just before we started
taping you know and this is this good
game and start a planets move it's so
fast that you're out of the game for
five years you're old you're out of
touch and you know the models that might
have worked 10 years ago 15 years ago 20
years ago when some of these professors
themselves might have been startup
entrepreneurs like me or worse academics
we never had an operating job in
start-up land and have a great theory
about this or that and then they're
teaching a class with no actual
experience building product and building
companies that's really dangerous
so at Harvard we've tried to create a
lot of fluidity with current
entrepreneurs coming in and out as
entrepreneurs and residents and guest
lecturers and advisers but it's really
hard to do that well in a lot of these
environments where maybe they don't have
access to as many great founders
floating around because great founders
are only sitting in three or four or
five
around the world in a night volume over
the past week I've been trying to think
through what I would do if I were a
Business School Dean like and you know a
Business School Dean with no shackles on
and time and time again I come to this
thought that like I probably can't
change my teachers fast enough and I
probably can't unsay Loeb my
organization fast enough or effectively
enough and so the one thing that I can
do is I can control who I accept and so
one thing I wonder is like do you think
we're going to see a day relatively soon
where a school like HBS is going to
accept you know one-third of its
students will have engineering
backgrounds or will be you know people
who actively write code because I mean
the one thing I think about is that like
that in and of itself would create an
environment where you wouldn't have to
change anything else you just put the
right people in that room they
organically become friends with each
other but they can find technical
co-founders right within their class is
that in the cards do you think I think
it's a great question
I'll give you one data point in my class
of 100 students this year four and this
is an entrepreneurship class for second
year MBA is the most ardent entrepreneur
bound students take their buildings only
four or five can write code we're out of
100 so now 15 or 20 are taking code
Academy courses or you know Flatiron
school courses or Coursera courses
trying to get facile in software
development and at least familiar but
it's a pretty small number I think it's
more likely yeah at applying we spent a
little bit but I think it's more likely
that they're going to add more
analytical skills and coding skills as
part of the curriculum really like
basically let's see if we can teach
business to business school kids how to
code more about let's teach business
school kids the product prototyping
skills and technical architectural
skills to be a good businessman
Jers effective accompanies I don't think
we're going to teach coders but I think
we can do a better job teaching managers
of technical companies so assuming that
we can't change the composition of the
school I guess the second thought that I
had around this was is there any way
that a set of courses offered at
business schools could be radically
changed in order to almost mandate a
50/50 engineer or non engineer
population so in other words you know if
we can't make it so that 50 percent of
the folks who are at HBS know how to
code can we create a class where we grab
people who do know how to code from
elsewhere in Harvard and that's like a
required ratio because I do think that
men it's really hard to meet people
outside of class where you live and like
the normal school activities I think
it's a great suggestion and there's
definitely a lot of that percolating at
Harvard and at MIT by the way MIT does I
think a better job with integrating
technical people into the MBA program
what's happening at Harvard is the
School of Engineering and Applied
Sciences is physically moving props
River across the Charles River to be
co-located with the Business School and
that's a multi-year project it's been
funded by folks like Steve Ballmer and
John Paulson others create a lot more
social engagement as that opens up to
2019 and 2020 in fact I'm already seeing
classes that exact as being considered
by the Business School that kid exactly
what you're saying
I think taking classes at the end of
Mighty Media Lab I love it because it
shows that they're mingling with the
engineers and with the visionaries and
with the futurists and I think we all
know great startups and great ideas come
from cross-pollination and and that's
why the silo thing is so heartbreaking
to me because we have so many really
smart kids
getting siloed in these narrow lanes and
I know when you see geographically with
the YC group but I think if you're not
in cities where you're seeing a lot of
cross-pollination it's a real
disadvantage
you know those entrepreneurs so that
kind of relates to what I was wondering
which is like we're talking about a lot
of this like top-down organizational
structure of business school program and
I was wondering Jeff if you had run into
people who just on their own had been
incredibly successful I like making
those technical connections and like
doing some of that cross pollinating
because you know what we're talking
about is like it's HBS right it's the
cream of the crop and so what if you're
at an MBA program that's not that and
you're you know in the middle of a place
that like might not be focused on tech
what have you seen people do that has
been successful that someone who's
getting their MBA who just got their MBA
can replicate yeah look I think it's
hard it's on a platter for you at
Stanford at MIT and harder that's not on
a platter for you in other environments
where you can't just walk out the door
and take a list in or a subway and find
you know a fantastic bunch of technical
people running around in a coffee shop
so you know what do people do in
Indianapolis what do people do in st.
Louis where people doing you know
elsewhere in the country in Ohio
Michigan I think it's hard but look
there are engineering programs computer
science programs in all these places and
there's also a ton of online tools and
we have an entrepreneur in Boston as an
AI and Kentucky and he just hustled his
way to build the network of angel
investors and software developers that
AI specialist has become really plugged
in to the AI community in Kentucky to
Boston subsequently but he got his
company off the ground and funded out
because it was possible so it does take
a little extra hustle and a little extra
connectivity what about breaking these
other these other molds so you know
research verse MVP what are the things
that someone can do to to get out of the
research mindset
I mean I have to be honest like the
number one reason why people stay in
research is they can't build their MVP
like this is one of things I often say
to founders is that this is a hard
problem but it's not a complex problem
I'm like these aren't complex issues
these are not counterintuitive issues
but if you have a bunch of people who
are trying to build the technology
business and they don't have access to
people who write code the path is going
to be harder I think the one thing that
always gets me is every entrepreneur has
the sense of hustle and when I see
founders overextending the hustle to
compensate for these core issues you
know that's what what often kind of
frustrates me is that like okay you know
we don't have technical founder but man
I found some dude in India who's going
to build this thing for me like don't I
deserve a pat on the back like I got
through that no technical co-founder
challenge and it's as if no one's
telling them that though some things are
foundational like some things you can't
hustle around or if you hustle around
them you're decreasing your chances of
success significantly and I don't know
how to communicate that to people it's
really strange because I mean like we
talk about this stuff all the time at Y
Combinator but people still apply
without this information and you know
over the past two weeks I've talked to a
number of kind of directors of
entrepreneur senators and the constant
thing that I'm surprised by is that they
know these things that I'm talking about
but they still accept teams that don't
abide by these rules so so they're kind
of rewarding something that they know is
going to necessarily make these team's
lives harder I don't really understand
why like that's like like no VC would do
that but like you know the head of an
entrepreneurship program and the
university like for some reason that's
completely acceptable one of the
insights that I feel like
people meditate you know look I'm a
venture capitalist by day so I totally
get his attention but one things that we
should be careful to distinguish is the
purpose of the university is not to
create billion dollar startups it's the
habit pedagogical experience for their
students and so it may be that there's a
little bit of a mismatch of goals here
you know subject look at incentives
goals because the fees of course are
going to put entrepreneurs really hard
as there's this I mean am I good you
don't get funding unless you're taking
the right approach but in a university
environment the attitude is hey you're
here to learn so you know we'll be a
little softer we'll let you you know run
through hoops let your monkey
experiments sakes and it's you're still
going to have your nice dorm room and
your nice classroom and your and if
you're gone the next day
you know you're not gonna not going to
go out of work and was your job you lose
your funding so there is a little bit of
a a coddling maybe is the thing to say
that MBA programs do put forward but
they're doing it for the reason of just
providing you know because they're
providing an academic and pedagogical
focused goal I think so that's my
challenge though because there are some
areas of a university that it's clear
they're trying to expose all of the
students in a very open and honest way
but there are many other areas of
universities that are completely locked
behind prerequisites and recommendations
and that are extremely exclusive I mean
for example I had there was a whole
major at Yale where I went to school
that you had to apply to even be able to
major in that subject they're learning
yeah after getting into Yale you have to
apply to be able to do this major and so
it's interesting to me that there's this
mental framework that entrepreneurship
is at the kind of 101 level and and only
there when if you look at the odds I
mean we're talking about the same odds
of becoming an NBA basketball player
and there is no high school team that
accepts everyone who walks in let alone
college right so so it's once again it's
like you know if I want to go to a 400
level physics class and I walk in the
front door and I don't know how to do
calculus I'm not staying in that class
for very long
and that's undergrad so I'm not really
asking where is the place for the 101 I
think that that should exist what I'm
asking is what's the 400 level class
because the one thing that we've noticed
here YC is that the best people only
want to be around the best people and if
you put a class together and you're
trying to attract the best but you also
are in the 101 man that's hard it's
really really hard so sometimes I feel
like the educational institutions are
not using all the tools they could and I
think this is a general theme there's
this general theme oh anyone can build a
billion-dollar company and it's like
sure anyone can but like it's kind of
like telling your kid that you can be a
rock star or you could be a Kobe Bryant
it's like it's a high bar so I think the
other thing that I'm trying to figure
out is what should people in the
meantime who are considering Business
School and want to be entrepreneurs what
should they do because I think that a
lot of people here in the valley would
argue that if you're a business person
you don't have access to a technical
network spending two years at an early
stage startup in the Bay Area might be
more fruitful than spending those two
years at a HBS or or a like school look
I think there is an argument for that
trade-off in the short term I think the
harder question for people is 10 years
from now 20 years from now 30 years from
now where am I going to end up because
if I spend the two years stepping off
the treadmill at Harvard or Stanford or
at MIT I'm going to come back with a
network
relationships and a skill set that may
not be immediately high ROI
and guide I had a lot of my students who
come from startup land and go back into
startup land at the same level that they
left after two years of spending a
hundred seven thousand dollars on their
MBA program yes brutal I've got a woman
I've been coaching was graduating this
year who's in that exact pose but ten
years from now twenty years now she's
going to be an awesome CEO and she's
going to have an extraordinary Network
and I don't know if she would have had
that I can't say should it have the same
benefits in the long term that she would
have she had never done the program but
let's push back on that like if she were
to build a successful company she
probably would have that Network right I
mean it's a lot easier to build a
network when you're doing something that
people are attracted to I think the risk
though is that do you have the tools to
scale as an executive while that company
scales you know looks look at Sheryl
Sandberg as an example when Sheryl if
she had never gotten an MBA and never
taken the two years out when she has
scaled an executive and as a leader at
Google and then later at Facebook or was
she enabled or enhanced because of her
two years at you know the MBA program C
I think I find that tricky because I
think that if you were to grab the
average person on the street in the
valley and or the average angel investor
in the valley they would say that that
MBA might have been much more of a
filtering and kind of rewarding process
than it was an educational process and I
don't know many people in the valley who
would say that you learn more getting an
MBA than you learn two years in the
grind at an early stage startup so it's
tricky it's tricky because like there
are a lot of MBAs have been successful
but they're also a lot of non MBAs that
have been extremely successful well to
present the other side there are a lot
of startup founders that are incredibly
unsuccessful go technical exactly and
technical yeah certainly being technical
is not
ticket to success I just suggest the
thing that I think about is that it and
I was there a lot of high functioning
mid-level people who get stuck as
directors and VP's yes I guess that's
the thing I think about I think the
thing I think about is not whether or
not the NBA can be valuable maybe a
better way of putting this is if I have
to choose to spend that hundred and some
thousand dollars and those ten years and
I also have the opportunity to be at an
early stage startup in you know a valley
or somewhere else how do I make that
decision and I think what I say to
people when I talk to young
professionals who asked me that question
is if you have high conviction that
you're in the middle of a Google or a
Facebook or a LinkedIn and urinating
you've got mentors and you've got a
great path then you should stick around
but that's a one in a thousand one in a
million situation you're in that
situation stay in it but if you're kind
of bumping around in the company that's
growing you know twenty percent forty
percent even 60 percent a year it's not
clear it's going to be a ten billion
dollar plus company then you would
benefit tremendously from taking two
years off the treadmill and to take a
page from Stephen Covey's book
sharpening the saw a little bit story
but the guy in the woods whose song like
crazy but so sloppy can read out hey why
don't you just stop and sharpen the saw
it's once you're busy sawing out of that
do you think that applies past the top
five business schools in the country no
that's a great point my friend I should
have said that the I did I say it's too
quick go to the top five which our city
we happen to be in the middle of
start-up land cities you know rich
innovation ecosystems yeah and and
that's it I'm not sure I would go to
others if I'm if I'm in the middle of a
start-up if I'm trying to transform
myself you know who knows but if I'm in
the middle of a startup that's going
well in New York or in Tel Aviv or in
Boston or soda Valley you know between I
want to name a school to be to you know
things but if it's an on top high school
then I'm not sure you go
so I think that that's I think that's
the extremely important point I think
that like I could say that hands down I
could say that if you're not going to a
top five school you are not technical
and you want to get into tech startups
it makes no sense to me why you wouldn't
try to get a job in an early stage
company in a startup city and I think
the one thing that people might not
realize is that people do not see the
NBA as a start-up what is that called
it's not seen as like a positive
resident resume item modeling credential
it credentials the word I'm looking for
so you better squeeze as much [__]
value out of it as humanly possible
because it's not going to be like oh
like that's on your resume here are some
extra points I think sometimes people
don't think about it that way and it's
interesting is my wife went to business
school and what surprised me more than
anything were the number of career
switchers at business school I think
people often I originally thought mostly
went to business school to advance
within their current career and
strangely enough more than half of her
class was doing banking or consulting
and then looking to do something else
and it was tricky because they were
pitched oh come to this business school
and will do this for you and then in the
end of the day they kind of got scooped
up into middle management from like you
know the big companies in the Bay Area
and I'm not exactly sure that's like
maybe that's better than banking I don't
know how but like I don't know if that's
so I think that you know the other thing
that I want to dig into is that what do
you do if you're a student and you know
you're not getting good advice I mean
like you look at the person giving you
advice and you're like they are
legitimately not qualified to talk to me
about startups what do you think you do
like what would you advise a student in
that situation I mean I think it's
amazing is I think the blogs of people
like Paul Graham
I'm at Brad Feld and Fred Wilson at the
books that have been written by those
folks or the in the case of Brad and
others you know I mean those are the
real valuable pieces of content you know
if you're not learning air Greece's book
if you're not taking reading four steps
to the Epiphany by Steve Blank you're
not seeing that content in your class
you're the wrong class so that's the
advice I give is like make sure you're
reading the Canon like there exists a
Canon and startup landed that you know
if you're not studying the Canon then
it's like trying to be a minister
without you know you know memorizing the
Bible totally agree and I think the last
question is you know in my mind is you
talk about what I see when I see these
students you know you guys are much
higher in the food chain a lot of times
I assume MBAs think that they can they
can and should just raise from VC
straight away so what happens when you
see these folks were the challenges that
you have in investing in an MBA student
when they come to your directly to you
it's the same thing you're pointing to
it about at an additional spin to it we
as a VC only invest in massive market
opportunities and truly transformational
disruptive industries and upper end
markets and so if an MBA has a cute app
or a neat little business spin on
something that's well-trod that's not
investable for a venture capitalism it
needs to be something really
transformative and to get something
transformative you need to have vision
and you need to see a lot of white space
where no one else is seeing it and that
does tend to happen from technical
founders often it can happen from
business founders but it's got to be
some special I mean blue apron is a good
example that's a purely business model
insight that of a business and a Harvard
MBA you know
discovered and will state that company
is as successful as it seems to be but
you know that's that's a great example
of something disruptive and
transformative it was purely based on
the business model yeah totally I
totally agree with that all right well I
think we're running into time here so
Jeff this was awesome thank you man yeah
great great to chat with you about it
thanks you give me the opportunity
you